thanks guys Viviano what a game so Queen
d1 was very interesting on his part I
mean it was a very aggressive attempt to
try to gain some some play in the
position now later on though are you
aware that you missed Queen g6 after
Queen c6 check King F aid you played
Queen a a check and it's like Queen g6
here yeah Queen g6 is winning by force
forces Queen g3 check trading into the
the end game that is very simple they
can imagine that after you know five and
a half six hours of play that it's easy
to overlook something like that what is
the fatigue like toward the end of a
game like this um I didn't feel tired
but somehow I I thought I thought I
needed to do something a bit more clever
I don't know I should maybe I just
rushed but yeah Queen g6 is very simple
and what are your thoughts earlier in
the game whenever he does play Queen d1
um that seems like he could do a lot of
play allowing you to play a six-track
bringing the Queen and Bishop battery uh
chubbier I thought it was already
unpleasant for him and he was in time
pressure so it wasn't easy to defend he
was trying something active but uh but
it's probably not good and in a
situation like that do you tend to try
to keep the position very sharp whenever
your opponent is low on time and you're
approaching the time control oh no I was
trying to pose problems for him um I
think I also made pretty decent moves up
to a point absolutely thank you very
much for your time back to you guys